Oh
um I think it may have something to do
with the myth of the gala to at least
the ideal of Galit arianism that it's
better to be a regular guy with sort of
good standing in the community good
character and so on than to be an
egghead eggheads are suspected and
that's not just American culture I think
that's that was true traditionally in in
in Britain as well and there's something
to be said for it I mean there are there
many unpleasant effects of that kind of
phillotson Philistine ism but the good
thing is that ideas can be dangerous
intellectuals are dangerous when you
give them too much power because they
tend to take ideas to their extreme and
they're not practical people on the
whole and it's good I think to be a
little suspicious of taking idea any
idea to its extreme and it's probably
better to have people in power who are
more practical and who can who know the
art of compromise
well I think he would be on the one hand
probably shocked because some of his
possibly some of his his worst his most
pessimistic predictions would seem to
have come true in that he he he was on
the one hand in favor of democracy and
he admired American democracy but he was
frightened of the possible consequences
he thought it could lead to tremendous
vulgarity and so on and I think he
probably would see that and he would
also see a much less conformist
population probably than the one he saw
depending on where he would he would
travel of course and I think he probably
would be rather shocked by the tone of
the public figures of the politicians
who are probably less little less
high-minded than the ones that he
encountered when he was there